[Music]
before we start the video
i just wanted to ask everyone to if you
enjoyed the content
please like subscribe and hit the
notification bell so that we can keep
these videos going
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
parcel tongue the language of snakes
more specifically i'm going to be
addressing a moment in the deathly
hallows
where ron is able to speak the rare
that's an understatement
language and enter the chamber of
secrets for many
this was confusing and that's because in
spite of an attempt at explaining it
it just doesn't make a lot of sense
furthermore there's a bit of a different
explanation
for how he was able to do it from book
to film
i've got an interesting theory for how
he was able to do it
so hear me out without further ado let's
dive into it
harry potter is known for a lot of
things but one thing in particular about
harry
that is known amongst the student body
is that he can speak a parcel tongue
he's a parcel mouth
because harry had a piece of voldemort's
soul inside of him he inherited certain
abilities
and the ability to speak to snakes was
one of them if you didn't know already
a pastor mouth is one who is able to
speak parseltang the language of snakes
it's a hereditary trait that is passed
on through descendants of salazar
slytherin
which voldemort happened to be so it
makes sense that harry would inherit
this trait
it's widely accepted that salazar was
the original parcel mouth
but others have speculated that it may
in fact have been
herpa de fowl the original horcrux
creator
who lived before salazar sutherin's era
either way
descendants of salazar himself carried
this trait which is probably why the
connection is so strong
between slytherin house and snakes it's
their house emblem after all
it's really not a common thing but harry
of course doesn't realize this
until the chamber of secrets when it's
pointed out to him
before the chamber of secrets he speaks
to the snake in the zoo in the
philosopher's stone
and given that at that point in time he
was entirely ignorant to magic in its
entirety
he probably didn't know what to think of
it however it is only later on
that harry actually discovers that being
a parcel mouth is quite a unique trait
when none other than ron points it out
to him so
said harry i bet loads of people here
can do it oh no they can't
said ron it's not a very common gift
harry this is bad
you see when a part of mouth speaks
parcel tongue and speaks to snakes
to an outside observer he is speaking
the language of snakes
but to the speaker all they hear is
themselves speaking normally
this is why speaking to snakes is a
hereditary trait and not a learned skill
and i think that rowling makes this
quite clear however
in the deathly hallows when hermione and
ron have the idea to enter the chamber
of secrets
and retrieve a basilisk fang to destroy
the remaining horcruxes
they are without harry and if you'll
remember from the chamber of secrets
you need to speak parcel tongue to get
into the chamber
so what happened next well ron somehow
opened it
somehow ron spoke a parcel tongue from
the deathly hallows
and then he skidded around a final
corner and with a yell of mingled relief
and fury he saw them ron and hermione
both with their arms full of large
curved dirty yellow objects
ron with a broomstick under his arms
where the hell have you been
harry shouted chamber of secrets said
ron
chamber what said harry coming to an
unsteady halt before them
it was wrong all ron's idea said
hermione breathlessly
wasn't it absolutely brilliant there we
were after we left
and i said to ron even if we find the
other one how are we going to get rid of
it
we still hadn't got rid of the cup and
then he thought of it
the basilisk what something to get rid
of horcruxes
said ron simply so hermione and ron
entered the chamber
but how did they get in there the book
and film have different explanations
from the book but how did you get in the
chamber of secrets
harry asked staring from the basilisk
fangs to ron
you need to speak parcel tongue he did
whispered hermione
show him ron ron made a horrible
strangled hissing noise
it's what you did to open the locket he
told harry apologetically
i had to have a few ghosts to get it
right but he shrugged modestly
we got there in the end as we can see
here the explanation for ron being able
to speak parcel tongue
or at least enough to open the chamber
is that he remembered it from harry when
he opened the locket
the movie explanation is similar except
ron simply explains to hermione
that he heard it from harry while he was
sleeping harry talks in his sleep
have you noticed it's all a bit unusual
particularly as parcel tongue is
at least in my eyes so clearly
established as a unique ability
that no other person outside of salazar
southern's lineage
can ever learn or speak rowling had an
explanation for this in an interview
albeit wasn't a very good one since ron
is able to speak parcel tongue in the
last book
does that mean that parcel tongue is a
language that most witches and wizards
can learn
or must a person be born with some
ability to speak parcel tongue
i don't really see it as a language you
can learn so few people speak it that
who would teach you
this is a weird ability passed down
through the slytherin bloodline
however ron was with harry when he said
one word in parcel tongue
which i do not know so i cannot
duplicate for you but he heard him say
open and he was able to reproduce the
sound
so it was one word whether he could
learn to speak to snakes properly is a
separate issue
i don't think he could but he knew
enough he was smart enough to duplicate
one necessary sound
the issue with this explanation is that
if you are able to reproduce
one sound why can't you reproduce two
sounds
three sounds what's stopping you from
putting these sounds together
additionally when people speak parcel
tongue it doesn't even sound like
something that is achievable
by a human voice box it's a strange
ethereal sounding language
that sounds magical so how can it just
be replicated like that
here's what i think i don't think that
ron can speak parcel tongue
not in any way shape or form nor can he
understand it
he can however interpret sounds and
noises made from other people
and attempt to replicate them ron
doesn't even know what he's saying when
he opens the chamber
he just memorized what harry said
additionally in the passage above
ron's attempt at parcel tongue comes
across as strangled hissing
to harry which indicates that no it
wasn't parcel tongue
because if it was then presumably harry
would be able to interpret it
and understand it in the same way that
the entrance to the chamber of secrets
did
what this tells me is that rather than a
requirement for
actual parcel tongue to be spoken to
open the chamber
it's more about the language's phonemes
phonemes are any of the perceptually
distinct units of a sound
in a specified language that distinguish
one word from another
and the fact that ron is able to open
the chamber tells me that the phonemes
of parcel tongue
differ from the language itself if that
wasn't the case
then harry would have been able to
understand ron when he attempted parcel
tongue
this means that the entrance of the
chamber doesn't open to parcel tongue
it opens to a spoken password that
resembles parcel tongue
and contains the same phonemes i think
that this is really the only logical
explanation
for how someone like ron could leverage
a rare hereditary language
he knew some sounds that sounded like
parcel tongue and uttered them
but it wasn't the real language however
it was enough to get in
what do you guys think do you think that
ron actually spoke parcel tongue
or do you think that my phoneme theory
is a little bit more accurate
was this just a bit of an oversight from
rolling altogether
i'd love to hear what you guys have to
say on this topic so leave a comment
down below
until next time there is plenty to be
learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
you